It is really valuable to have someone who
has direct contact
with the customers also involved
in building the product.
And so, that's kind of
what led me to be
in a more technical role
and to eventually have
a team of engineers on my own.
Jennifer Richard, thank you so much
for joining me on 20 Minute Leaders.
How are you?
Doing well, thank you
and thanks for having me.
Thank you very much for being here.
You started off
being an English major,
somehow you find your way
into tech, but not just tech,
you going across being
a founding member
of a few different ventures.
Venture back ventures
and then a climbing into the VC space
at the second fund,
I believe that you're at now.
And now you're a principal
at Bonfire Ventures,
leading a seed stage rounds.
Tell me a little bit
about your background
and how do you transition
from English Major,
to doing what you're doing today?
Yeah. So, I think a lot of it
was just some opportunistic moves
and a little bit of luck,
but I have always enjoyed writing.
When I went to college,
I knew that I wanted to pursue English
and was thinking about
maybe going into law.
After that,
I quickly realized after taking
a couple of law classes that
that wasn't what I wanted to do.
And I ended up graduating
and just not having any idea.
And it was also during
the last financial crash.
So, not a lot of opportunities
in terms of jobs.
So, I ended up moving into entertainment.
Working at CAA,
which is one of the world's
biggest talent agencies.
I was there for about three years,
went through the training program there.
And in that time we represented people
like Eric Reese, Gary Vaynerchuk
and several other
just huge entrepreneurs.
And what they were doing seemed
a lot more interesting than
what I was doing.
And I saw there was
a blossoming tech ecosystem
happening in LA.
And so, I decided to take the leap,
joined the startup,
just scaling customer support, at first.
After a couple of months,
that company was acquired.
And I got to move into
a more technical role
at the founders next pivot.
And so, from there,
that's kind of what started
just my career in tech.
Building companies, selling them,
building and eventually
I decided that what the
our investors were doing
also seemed really interesting,
and went to school
to ultimately move into VC
and that's how I made my way
where I am right now.
Right. So, you're doing
your MBA in Berkeley
with the hope to make it
into the VC space.
What was it about the VC space
that really resonated with you
that you felt compelling
for you to go and work there?
Yeah. So, I think
there were a couple of things.
The biggest one was that,
I worked at a couple
of different startups
and like most startups,
there were some issues
with our culture
and, you know, issues with diversity.
And I realized how hard it is
to make the change from within,
within the company.
It really was,
our investors who had the most power
and the people
who are deploying the capital
who have the most influence on
what the ecosystem looks like, literally.
And so, I think that was
my biggest motivating factor
to get into VC
was to be able to influence
who's getting money,
what kind of responsibilities they have,
holding founders accountable,
and also just being able
to support this ecosystem I love,
without being in siloed
into one company
and always working
on one specific problem.
And so, I think that
the blend of those two things
is what makes VC a perfect fit for me.
And ever since I moved in
a few years ago, I just love it.
I love that.
So, take me back a little bit
to this transition in your career.
Growing up,
did you imagine that you'll go into tech
that you'll be
an investor at a VC Fund,
especially this young?
No, absolutely not.
I didn't even know
what tacking a VC was
when I was growing up.
I'm first generation college,
and just a lot of the things
that I'm doing now,
I just had no exposure to
when I was a kid.
And so, when I was growing up,
the things I thought of were
the very traditional doctor, lawyer,
those kinds of career paths,
I just didn't even know
that this one was an option.
Wow.
And what really was it that made that?
So, you mentioned that
you were part of a company
that got acquired that
and then you transitioned
into a more techie role.
But it sounds like
there's a little bit more meed there
in terms of, you know,
the thought process
of making that transition.
What was that like
and what were some of the things
that perhaps either surprised you
or disappointed you in that transition?
Yeah, I mean,
when I was a kid,
so probably in elementary school,
middle school,
I taught myself how to code.
And so, that is definitely
what influenced me
to get into a more technical role
while I was in startups.
And you know, I think,
so, I was running customer support
at this first company,
at this first startup I was at.
And what was so interesting to me
was that we were getting
in so many different valuable pieces
of insight from our customers,
but there wasn't really
a established communication channel
between support and the engineers
who were building out our product.
And so, I was constantly,
you know, pinging the engineers
telling them we've gotten
this feedback from our customers.
I think we should make
this change on the site.
And at first, I got some pushback,
as I think support managers often do.
Excuse me.
But, eventually, our CTO
and our engineering team realized
this is affecting our bottom line.
And so, it is really valuable
to have someone
who has direct contact
with the customers also involved
in building the product.
And so, that's kind of
what led me to be
in a more technical role
and to eventually have a team
of engineers on my own.
Unbelievable.
And what were some
of the most exciting things
about being a founding member
of a few venture backed companies?
What were some of the highlights,
perhaps for people that aren't from tech
or aren't from the VC team,
that they're curious to hear about
that founding member experience?
Yeah. I mean,
I think that the biggest is,
you know, starting
from absolutely nothing
and just having this idea of a product
and then launching our MVP
and just knowing that
it could be so much better
but just having
a super crappy product.
And then just being able
to constantly see this evolution
and being in rooms where
you can take one path or another
and weighing out the pros and cons
and then executing on these different,
you know, on these different decisions,
and just seeing the way
that it impacts the company.
I think that, of course,
the biggest you know,
the most memorable moment
was finding out
that we were being acquired
and just seeing, you know,
years of work turn into something big.
And so, I think that there's so many
highs and lows in building
a company and it requires
so much teamwork and camaraderie.
And the people
that I worked with
at those startups are still some
of my closest friends.
And so, just being in the trenches
with a team of people
and having a singular vision
and getting it done,
it was just incredible.
Right.
Which aspects
of the entrepreneurial experience
do you take with you
in your role as principal at VC funds?
Yeah. So, I think it's really interesting
that VC funds are very small, typically.
And so, there is a very similar feeling
of wearing several different hats, like,
for instance, at Bonfire,
I'm sourcing investments,
I'm doing diligence,
but also doing marketing for the firm
and helping with strategy.
And so, there is no responsibility
that's too big or too small.
And that's very similar to the mentality
you have to have working in a startup
or starting an early stage company.
Because I can empathize
with our founders very much,
because it's a lot of us
just doing everything
and trying to pull things together
to make this thing work.
And, you know,
we have a similar feeling of grittiness.
And yeah,
I mean, I guess that's kind of my answer.
So, tell me a little bit about
your perspective in the VC space.
Whether it's sourcing deals
or doing due diligence,
what are some of the things
that you're particularly looking for
as either you're looking
for an interesting company
to source and to communicate with
or in the due diligence process
as a possible investment opportunity?
Yeah. So, I think that question
is two fold, because
I'm always looking for
the right company
and product market fit
and growing market.
So, the right opportunity
from the company perspective
and the product perspective
as well as the right teams to support.
And I think that the teams
are really important.
Because going back to
what I said previously about
having this responsibility
to impact culture and the landscape
and who's getting capital,
I want to invest in good people.
In people who are strong leaders
and who want
to empower their teams
and have diverse companies.
And so, I think that's one.
And then on the other side,
I want to invest in products
that are going to change the world.
If I would have been in VC,
back when the investors
were writing texts
in to Uber seed round
or Airbnb and just being able
to invest in companies
that fundamentally change
the way that people work and operate,
it is always the ultimate goal.
And so, any type of company
that is impacting a large growing market
and is providing a software solution
to help people work more efficiently,
live more efficiently, that's something
I'm really interested in.
Right.
Do you feel there's enough fair access
for people that don't come
from the tech world
into the tech world?
And I'm asking this because,
you know, it seems that,
especially 2020 is showing us
that diversity inclusion is
still an issue everywhere in the world,
also in the US.
And one of the things
that I've been thinking about
is the opportunities
that are presented
and breaking this cycles.
And you're mentioning that
you're a first generation college student
and you didn't even think
about going into tech,
let alone be a VC.
And one of the things
that have been curious
and challenging my thought process
with is, what are some things
that really should happen in order
for this industry
to become more accessible?
Whether it's through training
or through job opportunities
or entry positions,
to get people into the right,
into the hooks.
Because you mentioned
that one of the things
that got you in there
was a position
that you transferred to,
once you were already
sort of half a leg into this.
So, I'd love to hear your perspective.
And what do you think
we could improve on
or we could do?
Yeah. So, I mean,
I think that there's several angles
with which we have
to tackle this problem.
I mean, a big one
is having more diverse tech writers,
which is a big topic
of conversation right now.
Another one is increasing
the access to STEM programs
in schools
that house minority students,
which tend to be completely underfunded.
But I think that
the biggest issue right now
is that once
these underrepresented founders,
investors, et cetera,
actually get into a VC fund
or get into a startup,
those environments aren't inclusive.
And so many of them end up leaving
and taking a different career path.
And so, I think that
so much of this needs to happen
at the personal level
for leaders of these funds
and companies to do
the personal work
of understanding empathy,
understanding what it means
to have an inclusive culture.
And that work is really tough.
And a lot of people are afraid of it.
A lot of people avoid it.
But I think,
that's what needs to happen for us
to turn the needle,
move the needle.
So, how do you break
that cycle then?
Because you're mentioning a lot
of people are afraid of it,
a lot of people
don't even know where to start.
It's a taboo subject
in a lot of people's minds.
And, you know,
it's like a chicken and the egg.
You need to have diversity
in order for it to become less
of a taboo subject.
But you don't have the diversity
because it is a taboo subject.
So, how do you think
we can potentially start moving
the needle in the right direction?
Perhaps it's just a generational thing .
And the new generation
of perhaps entrepreneurs
are growing up in a more diverse world.
But what do you think
could happen already right now,
as somebody who's leading investments,
who's helping promote certain companies,
what do you think should happen?
Yeah. I mean, I think that
I'm seeing a lot
a huge surge in companies
that are hiring consultants,
for instance, to do, you know,
the introspective work
with companies and teams.
I think that there needs to be
more coaching for executives.
And I think that
so much of it needs to start
at the executive level individually
so that people can ask
the questions that they're afraid
to ask in front of a group of people.
And, you know,
they can get down
to the deeper issues of leadership
without bringing the whole company in.
And then I do think
that this needs to be
an exercise across companies.
And I think there is a feeling that,
you know, diversity is a political issue
or that these types of talks
don't belong in the workplace.
And until we get over that,
we're never going to be able
to talk about it.
And so, I think
that people need to work
on themselves,
on an individual level,
and then be willing
and courageous enough
to have these talks as a team.
I love that.
Thank you for sharing, Jennifer.
What does it mean to be a connoisseur
of a natural and biodynamic wines?
What is that?
And how do you even get that
as a passion?
Yeah, so I actually
started drinking natural wines
with my friends maybe about
a year ago and that has definitely--
What's a natural one?
Am I not drinking natural wine?
I don't know.
Probably not, though.
So, natural in biodynamic wines,
they're wines that are
created through processes
of very minimal intervention.
And so they're typically used
with organic grapes.
But organic and natural wines
are not the same.
It's more about
the prospect of minimal sulfites,
just minimal chemicals,
minimal intervention at all
in making them.
And they're very good.
For many people,
it's an acquired taste,
but it's just a cleaner drink.
You're not hung over the next day
and they're really delicious
and tend to be coming
from small local farmers,
much more sustainable
farming in general,
and so, better for the
environment as well.
Wow. That's wonderful.
And so, what is actually happening
with the wine market today
and why is this not a common thing?
Is it mainly pricing,
mainly the market?
So, I think it's actually becoming
more and more common.
and if you look in your city,
you will probably find
several natural wine makers.
I think that, or,
several shops that carry natural wines,
I think the biggest thing is that
the traditional wine makers are,
so, they're the incumbents.
It's kind of like in tech
and they have all
the money and all the power
and they're seeing the uprise
of this new natural wine movement.
And I am against it
and typically trying to cross it.
And so, I think that it's just a matter
of the smaller growers,
the smaller shops,
doing more marketing and figuring out
a way to convince people
that what they've been doing
for all of this time
is not necessarily the best.
And there's an alternative
that they can get
for a slightly higher price point.
It is a little bit more expensive
depending on what you're drinking.
100%.
That's very very interesting.
And I'm going to have
to check it out a little bit more,
because I had no idea that
this is even in market.
Or that I'm not drinking an actual one.
I thought that
when I was drinking wine,
I was drinking something very natural
and I feel almost cheated right now.
So, I'm going to have to work
that with myself later.
But, Jennifer, before we leave,
I have to ask you also
about your passion for e-commerce.
Because we didn't get
to talk about that yet.
But that is something
that you've been deeply involved
with the different companies.
And you mentioned that
it's a personal interest of yours.
Give me a little bit of a brief
about e-commerce
and why that is something
that you're so excited about?
Yeah. So, I think it starts with
my experience working in startups.
So, the companies that I was at,
one of them was
pure-play D2C e-commerce,
and then the other two
were ad tech or crowd funding
but had an e commerce element.
And so, all of my professional tech career
has been in e commerce
through some form.
And at the most recent company,
Pop & Suki,
I was actually employee number two.
Built e commerce from the ground up,
from literally nothing.
And so, I just understand
that pain point so deeply
of internationalization
or logistics and drop shipping,
conversion and mobile commerce,
and trying to optimize.
And so, it's just something
that I know a lot about.
And I think as an investor,
you tend to gravitate towards
problems and solutions
that you understand.
Because at the end of the day,
you're taking a bet
and you want to take a bet
with on companies for which you have
the most possible
context and information.
And so, that is definitely why I gravitate.
And also as a consumer,
I love online shopping.
I'm constantly
on different e-commerce websites,
stopping checking them out,
seeing what platform they're using,
how their site set up.
And so, it's just a natural passion
at the end of the day.
That's very interesting.
Thank you, Jennifer.
Before we leave, I want to thank you
for being generous with your time.
This was really, really great.
And I love hearing about your journey,
your interests,
your take on how we can improve
the tech scene today
in the industry as a whole.
And then lastly, discovering
that I've been cheated on
with my wine drinking.
So, thank you for that.
But Jennifer, before we leave,
I have to ask you
for three words that you would
use to describe yourself.
Oh.
I would say the three words
are adventurous,
sarcastic and curious.
I love that. I love that.
Jennifer, thank you very, very much.
This was a really, really great.
And stay safe and stay healthy.
Thank you.
This was so much fun.
I appreciate it.
And happy holidays.
Happy holidays.